in leopard on Myanmar a great land grab
is underway after decades of
dictatorship the country is opening up
to foreign investment for a joint
venture between a Chinese mining firm
one bound in a military owned company
authorities here have cleared more than
31 hectares of land the copper project
has averted hundreds of farmers from
their ancestral villages with no other
way to earn a living some displaced
farmers here turn over the remains of a
previous mining project for handfuls of
copper dust but others are prepared to
do whatever it takes to avoid a future
that looks like this what do you suppose
about that and everything that way to a
win was an ordinary farmer until a large
tract of her family's land was taken to
make way for the copper mine she became
an activist midnight listen really you
know when maybe you okay yeah lobby na
Tizen IVI lonely team is having a dance
ellonija going on the Aoyama when one
Bell employee started clearing more of
her family's land for the mind this year
wait we win tried to stop them I don't
even really like a Marilyn and a bull
run go for see me like that
no sorry maternal ago natalia makarova
renew paulo Corrado Haruna Dean I'm an
attorney viola bono when you name is
Revati luma Diana don't wanna live
working right in 2012 widespread anger
at the mine swelled into a protest
movement that attracted student leaders
and Buddhist monks
it remained peaceful but authorities did
not that November police attacked
protesters with white phosphorus
grenades an illegal weapon that
hospitalized more than a hundred months
with antal me and Phi Phi O'Hara I had
to go rule long thing at the ganya Wow
Yutaka Klan Jana joined the protest to
stop the destruction of sacred Buddhist
sites he was seated in prayer when the
grenade struck does it not be Allen that
was in an airborne Oh al you gotta come
out with me tonight
that Jana insists the order for the
crackdown came from the top of Myanmar's
government
a commission was formed to investigate
the leopard on violence but by own son
sushi the democracy activists who spent
15 years under house arrest for taking
on the military but her Commission
failed to hold any officials responsible
for the attacks on protesters prompting
locals to heckle the parliamentarian on
her last visit
in Myanmar there's no rule of law now
and Billy is a personal vanity never
bite we have so many Langevin hisses
Tintin
Oh as a lawyer in Mandalay who works on
behalf of the farmers he says the
military continues to operate with
impunity dismissing talk of democracy in
Myanmar and when you say that people are
not being compensated for their lands
money they must be the bug had Bailey
wanted man they'd never be enough
conversation money after 21 years behind
bars
Tenten who refuses to keep quiet because
this is our duty to abolish to eradicate
the most free garment if he proceeds we
have no future we are living in the
darkness Daniel Bono DC Meganium many
are not be any remaining so Yaga Daniel
would you look back when Peter lassally
oh sorry Darla I'm happy like that the
rest and threats have not silenced way
to win and farmers like her either
as the mine continues its expansion she
meets with other protest leaders in the
nearby village of kangaroo
most of these farmers have bailed on to
their land but they face a more
insidious threat a military on the
factory that makes acid for the copper
mine
they say their air water and crops are
poisoned causing serious and sometimes
deadly health problems
Yaya wins daughter is sick with an
illness whose name she doesn't know
four-year-old un wotty you was blind at
birth she can't speak walk or sit on her
own yo yo when's newborn son looks
healthy but she fears there will be
future complications given all the
pollution here do you want to move from
this place after several attempts our
translator Sano managed to arrange an
interview with officers from one better
the Chinese mining company so the
government justice is a land long ten I
really just come to the Me's office for
collectors comes
heavily I realized vision but I've
spoken with some farmers who said they
would not accept the government's money
and that bulldozers came to their home
in the middle of the night along with
armed men and forced them out so these
people are not telling the truth there
is an acid factory that is owned by the
military holding company nearby a lot of
residents are complaining about the
pollution there and some are saying they
have severe health complications at the
house issue
you can check with Ministry of the house
within the Kassadin this school is true
or not
back at our hotel later that night
Special Branch police agents showed up
to question us about our activities in
Lebanon they were asking about what
we've been up to
we've been talking to where we've been
today and you know we're trying to be
with these guys anyway so we took
advantage of the encounter to set up an
appointment with the police chief first
thing tomorrow morning
at first he tried to scare us off today
we feel very secure and we're in the
best hands here no problems may we ask
you some questions about the let padam
controversy white phosphorus is illegal
under international law and it was used
against civilians and monks in this case
Dunagan approves Yallah ta you really
are looking to do more I may not
actually met my nemesis you know that
even in situations of war these of white
phosphorus is considered a war crime and
you are saying that it can be deployed
against peaceful protesters
but as a mom yeah oh yeah oh dude I know
like them I told you daylight now
several thousand farmers have been
resettled by the government since the
joint venture with the Chinese mining
company started the next day we drove to
one of the largest camps to check out
the living conditions this time we had
company two guys had been following us
since we got selected on our motorbikes
I'm just gonna go see what their
business is are you following
we keep seeing you behind the car and
then we stopped here and then you
stopped here so we were just rude if we
went further down the road and we
stopped again you stuff that would be
really suspicious I think she's probably
the last time we're gonna see each other
so now we lost our special branch tails
and we have an immigration officer okay
it's all fun and games for us we have
press visas we're international
journalists but it's a lot tougher for
local journalists really imagine what
they have to put up with dealing with
this kind of harassment cute near a
suite and chickpeas on a five acre farm
Alma till the day a government truck
arrived and brought in here yeah I got
older the old man's son maash way now
works for one bow as a security let me
get the Negev and you
do it Nobita the Obama daughters
Japanese lol today was never be so quick
a new critical parent on top on top beer
toward the end of our interview Moshe
way admits the depression and alcoholism
are common in the camps and the reason
for his beat-up appearance
back in the village twice way winces she
won't be going in Obama's Akebono whoa
hello Bo demuccio's area holiday my by
Sally yanira drew a puny Java Python
you're evading the water al don't delay
yeah I don't really